- [Woman] Wait, are you serious?
- Yeah, what's wrong with this?
- [Woman] You look like you're
about to go to a hockey game.
- What's wrong with that?
- [Woman] You're not
going to a hockey game.
(both laughing)
- Sister knows best.
- [Woman] Yes.
(energetic music)
- I'm going to be getting
a sibling for a week.
Common misconceptions
of being an only child
is that you don't know how to share.
You want it to always be all about you.
Just kinda true.
I'm honestly really excited
to kind of have that companionship.
I've always wanted a brother.
When I was younger, I went to a mall Santa
and I asked for an older
brother for Christmas.
And he laughed in my face.
I didn't believe in Santa for
that much longer after that.
So I'm about to find out
who my sibling's gonna be.
I'm so excited and also very nervous.
Here we go.
(lullaby music)
Oh, Nyla, oh I'm so happy.
Oh my God.
So I'm so excited.
We're gonna be brother and sister.
So this week my parents are coming in town
for vacation so we're gonna be
cooking them a meal together
but we're also going to be going on
a family outing together.
- And at the end of the week,
we're going to be taking
a family portrait photo.
And I'm very excited for that.
- Me too!
I had no clue you were an only child.
- Yeah, just me.
- I don't know why anyone complains
about having a sibling.
- Watch as we're gonna
probably be arguing by day two.
- Nyla is heading down to the lobby
and we're about to meet her
and go to a museum together.
Are you ready?
- Yeah!
- I was a little nervous at first.
I know how my family operates.
I don't really know how other
people's family operates.
Hi guys!
- Hi Nyla.
- How are you, dad?
But then I fell in love
with them like instantly.
Didn't know you had a
daughter and now you do.
You walk up to a family that's not yours,
especially parents, they
either go by Mr or Mrs,
something very formal.
But Ben's parents were
just like, Mom and Dad.
And I was like, okay cool.
- So she just told us it
was four blocks that way.
- We went to the wrong
wax museum at first.
- Yeah.
- I think that kinda like broke the ice.
- Okay kids, don't cry.
We'll get you to the wax museum.
- Out of family disfunction, we were able
to share that moment and
it kind of set the tone
for the rest of the day.
- Yeah.
- We made it.
- We arrived!
- We're here.
- All right, let's do this.
- It was crazy because
at one point in time
we were walking.
I was kind of like a
little bit ahead of Ben
and his parents and this guy.
He's like, oh you should like smile more.
You need a hug.
- No he said, yeah, and I
was like, that's my sister.
- And then your dad was like--
you're about to get your ass kicked
if you keep messing with her.
- And I was like, okay, this is family.
I'm not even worried about it.
- The wax museum, we
kind of were able to like
break the ice and then the
family dinner the next day
was also a really great time.
- Where are we?
- We're at Trader Joes.
We're going to get dinner for our parents
and get groceries for the week.
- Yes.
Can you cook?
- I can cook, yeah.
- I can't.
- [Ben] Mom, dad, we're home.
- [Nyla] We have groceries.
- It definitely felt like a family dinner.
We were talking about a
lot of pretty deep things
and we got into it.
I took on the main course.
Nyla made the salad.
- The pre-made salad.
But I think that was
good because it was fun
to make something for our parents
and then also that I feel like gave
an opportunity for you to really sit down
and get to know them.
- [Mom] Cheers, everybody.
- [Everyone] Cheers!
- Cheers, great for my
family to get together again.
- The family dinner!
- The next day we had a family photo shoot
and it was corny as fuck.
- [Dad] It gives new meaning
to the word Facebook.
- But I think at that point it was like
we were so familiar with each other.
It was like so fun.
And as an only child, I know
I never went to the mall
and did like any sort of
portraits cause it's like,
that's something you
usually do with siblings.
My dad says that he's gonna send you
our newsletter this year.
Our family newsletter.
- [Nyla] Please do.
- And he wants to like
include one of those pictures.
All right so we just
finished our photo shoot.
- It was awesome.
- Yeah?
- It was a lot of fun.
I don't think I've ever done that.
- I wanna go back and do it again.
- My friend Nessa, I've
known her since kindergarten.
She recently moved out here and every week
she's been spending it with me.
She spent the day and the night with us.
She ends up becoming like the cousin.
- We were trying to not
have to cook anything.
So we got chicken and waffles and--
Look at the other side.
Yeah, so I tried.
We've got a whole box.
- I think we both kind
of have an understanding
of when it's time to be
like, oh, like let's chat.
And then it's like do your thing,
I'm gonna do my thing and we'll come back
together eventually.
- We also know common courtesy.
Like it's different if
we were like younger
or we didn't learn manners or social cues.
I think the only time we
kind of ran into anything
was like in the bathroom
because the stuff that
I have to do to get ready--
- Ben took the longest in the bathroom,
I just would like to say.
- All the stuff that I
do, I need a sink for.
Like I'm not gonna shave in your kitchen.
It's a process.
We went out at night with your friends
and it was like a situation where I was
out of my element but I felt so included.
It just felt like we were in it together.
It was fun.
- Yeah.
Goodnight brother.
- Goodnight, sis.
- I'll see you tomorrow.
It's been a week since
we've been siblings.
- It tried both of us like this week, wow.
We're hanging out on Saturday.
Nyla whips out of her garage
and we hear this thud.
And then we're like, oh
my god, you hit something.
And then it clicks in my head.
I was like, that's my car.
We turn around and sure
enough, there's my car.
Parked outside.
It was so funny too cause you were like,
oh my god, don't tell mom and dad.
They're gonna hate me,
they're gonna hate me.
It was tiring.
In times I was out of my element.
But I'm so glad that I
got this time with you.
I definitely feel like I consider
you family in some sense.
- Yeah same.
- Aw.
- Same!
It's like wild, we just clicked.
- Yeah.
You got a little peak of my family.
And like, I got a peak
of your family here.
The whole week there was
kind of this unspoken thing
where I feel like you had
my back and I had yours.
I appreciate that.
- I appreciate you.
- Aw, I appreciate you.
- I love you.
(happy music)
- I'm kind of happy we
didn't share the same room.
I like to masturbate so--
- Me too.